hey there folks I'm Walter Benassi AK
and this is top five we're taking the
week off from our Christmas theme
countdowns to celebrate the release of
spider-man into the spider-verse with
one of the Webb heads best animated
efforts the spectacular spider-man
animated series debuted in 2008 and
lasted only two short seasons its run of
26 episodes doesn't make this series one
of the longest tennard shows Marvel has
ever put out but it made an indelible
impact on television critics and fans of
spider-man to this day people still
speak of how well-developed the
characters and stories fell it focused
on a 16 year old Peter Parker in high
school dealing with his new spider
powers the recent loss of his Uncle Ben
interacting with his friends and most
importantly growing up one of the
aspects many fans point out is how
mature the themes are yet packaged into
a kid-friendly show anyone could enjoy
spectacular spider-man and that's what
made it stand out the lead story editor
and writer Greg Wiseman was a co-creator
of gargoyles in the 90s and went on to a
little show called Young Justice after
this to fight injustice episode stuff of
gargoyles episodes so with him and the
other talents guiding this series from
behind the scenes we know quality
control was important in this
incarnation of the wall-crawler but what
are the best installments of this show
it's time to find out these are the top
5 best spectacular spider-man episodes
number 5 first steps from season 2 this
episode did what a lot of the others did
well juggling multiple characters and
storylines in a coherent and exciting
way
it's flash Thompson's birthday while his
friends all gather at his house peter
has a lot on his mind
he's began dating Liz Allen but is still
trying to sort out his feelings for Gwen
Stacy and he keeps catching glimpses of
his missing frenemy Eddie Brock in
unexpected places also Harry Osborn has
returned from his long trip to get his
life back on track things are made even
crazier when the Sandman tries to rob an
oil tanker just a regular hectic day in
the life of Peter Benjamin Parker I'm
gonna try not to give too much away for
all these episodes but just in case this
is a
light spoiler warning I liked this
episode a lot because it furthers
development on so many long term arcs
while still delivering a great singular
story the format is also interesting
with video messages from Flash's friends
playing throughout the duration Eddie
Brock's return ends up being the most
important thing in the episode as he is
in search of where Peter left the Venom
symbiote early on we're not sure if
Peter is just seeing things or if Eddie
has indeed returned the Sandman's story
is handled very well here up until this
point Flint Marko was depicted as a
simple petty thief even after he gets
his sandman powers but it's in first
steps where we see him start to really
grow as a character somewhat playing off
Thomas Haden Church is depiction in
spider-man 3 this version of the
character is shown to have a few more
layers to him on a smaller note I really
liked where the show was heading with
Flash Thompson they obviously had bigger
plans for him if the show was to keep
going and we saw the seeds of that in
season 1 and here the fact that he and
Peter used to be best friends when they
were younger kids is an important aspect
of Flash's portrayal all in all a great
episode that feels like a microcosm of
why the show is of such high quality
number 4 the uncertainty principle from
season 1 the climax to the first Green
Goblin arc and much more make this
chapter a good one John Jameson and a
few other astronauts are in trouble when
a problem rears its head that could make
their trip back to earth deadly it's
also Halloween and the kids of Midtown
high are attending a local carnival when
trouble with the Green Goblin once again
services Peter is forced to leave to try
and stop it
Harry Osborn's addiction to the green an
Oscorp substance that gives him physical
and mental enhancements is out of
control when Stacy tries her best to
stop him but Harry's breaking point is
near the mature themes I mentioned
earlier are evident in how Harry's story
plays out in season 1 drug addiction and
how it affects those around you is a
heavy subject to cover but they did it
with class and presented it in a simple
enough way that kids could understand
Harry's dysfunctional relationship with
his father is also put on full display
giving this episode and emotional
resonance having this all in the
background as the Green Goblin arc was
peaking made this installment must-see
tombstone showing up for the final fight
made everything feel that much more
important and we even got to see a
little chink in the armor of Jay jonah
jameson i'm told that as the shuttle
enters Earth's atmosphere nasa will
likely lose contact
whatever happens foswell you'll give it
to me straight
sure JJ straight if you're a fan of the
Green Goblin or deeper development of
some of these side characters the
uncertainty principle is absolutely
worth checking out number three
nature vs. nurture from season 1 the
finale of season 1 was a highlight for
the series after Peter rejected the
alien symbiote it ended up bonding with
Eddie Brock in their mutual hatred of
spider-man and Parker together they
become venom and are out to destroy
everything its former hosts held dear
now peter has to fight an enemy who
knows his every move and all his secrets
I love this episode it's the culmination
of a great story with Eddie Brock and
Peter while setting up venom as the
show's latest and greatest threat how
they connected Eddie and Peter as
longtime friends was genius I wish this
was made into mainstream continuity
because it makes perfect sense and
deepens their rivalry told you this bro
we had no one we've always been alone
it's a more tragic art that was built
slowly through the first season and you
really feel for Brock he had everything
taken away from him and was seemingly
betrayed by his closest friend this
dynamic is my favorite in the series and
shows off the sacrifice Peter had to
make as spider-man and the consequences
of the well-meaning choices he made up
to this point while the Eddie Peter feud
is a lot of fun to watch it's not the
only thing happening in this episode it
may is still recovering from her recent
heart attack which has put Peter on edge
and the Peter Gwen friendship takes a
turn that was expanded upon in the
following season nature vs. nurture is
something special and unique from other
Spidey venom stories I dare say it could
be the best number two
final curtain from season two this
episode was the unintentional series
finale but ended things on a high note
spider-man in the resurfaced Green
Goblin are close to having a final
confrontation
Spidey seems to have deduced the goblins
identity which isn't the person he
originally thought the big reveal behind
the season two finale is a great payoff
to the goblins arc in the show it's
complex it's intriguing and also full of
potential as to where this series could
have went in a third season I can't talk
about it too much without completely
spoiling it but just trust me this one
was packed with entertaining twists and
turns and again the relationship of
Peter and Gwen takes up a good portion
of the story that development ended in a
great setup for more but as we know this
was the end of the road for spectacular
spider-man
[Music]
and the number one best spectacular
spider-man episode if intervention from
season 1 how Peter breaks free of the
symbiotes grasp in this episode is what
spider-man is all about Peter
accidentally acquired his new symbiotic
black suit a few episodes prior and
slowly his personality has been changed
sure he's under a lot of stress with
Aunt May in the hospital but lately he's
been pushing away his friends and
getting much more hostile when he
realizes what the black suit has been
doing to him he tries to get rid of it
however the symbiote is not so easy to
dispose of it forcefully takes Peter on
a journey inward it is within his own
mind that Parkers will is tested to the
fullest extent possible we see glimpses
of spider-man's classic origin here as
well as a manifestation of Uncle Ben
that gives us a deep insight into what
makes Peter Parker tick it uses a lot of
scene setups and dialogue from the first
Sam Raimi movie to illustrate how Peter
accepted that with great power must come
great responsibility
Peter defending his own consciousness is
fascinated seeing how all that plays out
made me fall in love with this show also
we get one of those little wisdom scenes
with flash that rounded him out as a
character yeah yeah your aunt's sick
poor puny Parker even Sally feels bad
for you but not me
if you're hanging up on the xi geek that
proves you're still stuck up egghead a
guy who can't even see when his friends
are trying to help intervention is my
favorite episode it's one of my favorite
Spiderman stories in general because of
how they visually depicted Peter
struggle to reject the symbiote
obviously this is my top recommendation
it's unfortunate that spectacular
spider-man was canceled mostly because
of Disney purchasing Marvel and the
rights for the show falling into
corporate limbo it's a good thing that
we will never again be denied something
so amazing because of complicated legal
red tape Oh since watching this show for
the first time years ago I've always
compared it to 1994 spider-man the
animated series on my personal channel
this week I asked which is better it's
spider-man vs. spider-man in a new video
up now I want to hear what you guys
think what is your favorite spectacular
spider-man episode
what do you want us to cover next in the
show leave a comment and let us know to
keep in touch you could like my Facebook
page or follow along on Twitter we'll
catch y'all right back here next week as
we shift back into Christmas time on a
brand new episode of top 5 excelsior you
know when you put your tongue on the
side of the ship and it sticks there I
hate when I do that just sayin
[Music]
[Applause]
you